do you want to talk about this article
in The Daily News sure what a comedian
had a McDonald lived in fear of Chelsea
Hannah she said oh I lived in fear of
Chelsea Handler now do you think there's
any validity to this or do you feel like
this is a low blow when I found out at
work that she was trading stories to Us
Weekly about my personal life in
exchange for having her photograph run
in the magazine oh that is when I could
have fired her I did not fire her she
had a job for four more years I never
hung out with her personally again
because I took betrayal on her she was
living in fear and she wasn't fearful I
mean it's not an internment camp if
you're that fearful then get a job right
what are you talking about and then she
made a comment about me not discussing
my renewal like when I was quitting my
job why the [ __ ] would I talk to her
about what I was doing she's a writer on
my show she's not my partner you should
absolutely not discuss you talking to
Gary about what you're gonna do do you
talk to Gary no exactly I don't you can
do so many things to me before you sell
a story to a tabloid about me or not
sell it exchange it for a [ __ ]
picture of yourself
yeah rather you sold it I don't wait
yeah I feel that's a huge betrayal you
continue to employ her no you tortured
her no but you didn't fire her after
that she went on tour with me the last
year of my show so she's so scared of me
she was opening for me in places like
you know in Northern California at a
winery like if she was so she's so full
of [ __ ] I think she's a good person
she's talking about you I don't thank
you Heather
yeah I don't agree with how she treats
relationships in her life Jesus Christ
I think she's missing out by dumping
people I do end relationships when I
feel like I've been you know I do but
I've never ended a relationship without
letting that person know exactly what
they did so you talked her absolutely
yeah and she by the way that's what she
deserved
she did like 80 things that she should
have been fired for but out of the good
like she was good on the show she was
funny and I thought you know what
just separate yourself from her
personally
you